Here's another function for us to consider. This time, we have f of x equals x
times x minus 2 times x minus 2 times x minus 1 times x minus 1. Well, this is
interesting. We have some repeated factors here. So far, we've only seen
polynomial functions. That have unique zeros or all factors with different
zeros associated with them. In the past when we were looking at these functions
with unique zeros the number of zeros was always equal to the degree of the
polynomial. I wonder if that's the case if we have some zeros that are repeated
instead? Let's use this function to check that out. What I'd like you to do to
analyse this function then is to enter the x value of each of its zeros and
then tell me how many times each of those factors associated with those zeros
occur in the equation for the function. So if you said that one of the zeros
was four for example, and you saw the factor x minus 4 three times in this
equation, you would write a three right here. Lastly, I'd like you to add up
the total number of zeros that we have. This total number should just be the
sum of all of the numbers in this repeat boxes. Think, then, about how this
should relate to the total number of factors we see in this equation.